hello there guys so we have the delete
description for the new Ant-Man and the
WASP trailer which was shown behind
scenes so let me break it down for you
Scott hope and Cassie are all in a car
ride together Scott is listening to an
audiobook of his own book on the car
radio Cassie is weirded out by the fact
that he does this the scene then Cuts
just got happily doing mundane things
with a voice over of him reflecting on
his past actions we see Cassie being
released out of a jail cell presumably
because she's been getting into trouble
and Scott is there to take her home
Scott is then about to leave an ice
cream store and someone mistakenly yells
thank you Spider-Man Adam then we see
Cassie Scott Hank and Janet in a garage
or lab of some kind and Cassie reveals
that she's been studying the quantum
realm and the five years that everyone
was blimped she's built some device that
allows one to make contact with the
quantum realm it's a glowing blue orb of
energy that hovers over machine Janet
realizes what Cassie is doing and tells
her to shut it off in the midst of a
coral the device emits to Shockwave and
sends everyone flying back before
pulling them all and transporting them
into the quantum realm they're all wake
up hazy and confused and several things
are happening before Bill Murray's
character appears out of a ship and
reunites of her like their long-lost
friends we then see Kang's guards
apprehending Cassie and escort in her
and coughs Scott is in a room of Kang
and Cassie is in the cell right behind
them Kang states that he's killed so
many Avengers that they've all Blended
together he then offers Scott a deal to
help him retrieve something that he lost
and after Scott refuses can uses some
type of magic to bind Scott to the wall
so judge him by the breakdown of the
trailer and I also did listen to the
leaked audio of it the first half of
this trailer is more like light-hearted
and they got a couple jokes in there and
then the second half of the trailer the
tone completely changes to something
more dark more urgent and like you know
this is going to have a big impact on
the MCU and Kang's lines are really
really good so one of the lines is Scott
asks cure you and he says just man who's
lost a lot of time like you but we can
help each other with that someone stole
something for me and you're the only one
who can steal her back so do we have a
deal in which Scott responds no I don't
think we do so I'm really excited for
the more serious tone and of course I'm
most excited to see Kang but what do you
guys think let me know what you think of
this leaked trailer description in the
comment section below and what are you
most looking forward to to seeing in
this film thanks for watching guys